he's and they're off and here we go the
armageddon in the final
okay so king's pawn opening magnus
carlsen opening with the italian game
we've seen him do this plenty of times
before
he tends to do this in must-win
situations it's brought in many wins
against nakamura white castling the king
black pushing upon but i expect to see
black's king castle as well very shortly
magnus's strategy is to keep the pieces
on the board that's clear from this
opening he would have gone for something
else
a different opening if that wasn't his
plan so now black has castled magnus
just planning
maybe a way to maintain maximum tension
and wesley playing quickly up to this
point only spent
nine seconds magnus a bit more pushing
now pawns on that left flank
he has to make wesley he has to give him
decisions that's the key thing
he's pushing paul's trying to trap
black's bishop yeah and
uh wesley just pushes pawn one square
forward um totally agree with you there
the pieces must stay on the board and
one thing that i've noticed magnus
really likes is he loves to expand as
much as possible with the pawns
on the left side and wesley reinforcing
the center
whilst uh yeah what is white going to do
just push one pawn
forward or start the big re-maneuver of
the pieces
whatever magnus does he shouldn't be in
creative mood right now his time
advantage is almost gone already he's
only 20 seconds up
on the clock now he should be trying to
be too creative reacting is actually
easier in chess it's quicker to do that
and okay black bringing his knight back
there i expect to see white remaneuver
as you mentioned javanka
yeah no he expands in the middle of the
board this position i'm pretty sure i've
seen
this or something very similar at least
before in the past
magnus creating maximum tension in the
middle and wesley trading a set of pawns
uh will we see wesley so advanced in the
center actually i think i've had the
sixth position myself before
in st louis a couple years ago as black
and it didn't go well after white pushed
his central pawn
like that suddenly wesley's knight has
to run away from the center
there's you can take white's bishop on
the left side but white's pawn would
take the black knight and actually
explode open black's king position
when i had this in the past i was
terrified with black black is under the
attack
at this early stage and magnus starting
to re um
build up that lead on the clock again
yeah definitely and one thing that you
can notice is that with the
white pawn so far advanced the white
bishop can actually drop down
just one square towards the center and
then it's on the perfect
diagonal wesley has frozen there's no
time in arborgadon chest for a think of
over 30 seconds
suddenly he's been called out in this
opening magnus has tricked him
and suddenly black needs to move that
knight just move it you need to find a
safe square any square at this point but
more than one minute down on the clock
edge of the board
um okay and magnus drops his bishop all
the way down to the bottom a little bit
concerned about that knight being on the
edge
because look at the look at it on the
eye line of the queen okay so
wesley re-rooting the night but this
does give
time and uh knight now jumping into the
attack and all the time
magnus is ahead on the clock putting
pressure on the position
blacks knights they have jumped around
they are defending each other but they
will get kicked back sooner or later so
magnus just gaining space first
gaining some time by pushing uh the
black pieces backwards
i expect to see magnus at some point not
yet
but he will lift up his rook in the
corner what he loves to do this magnus
move up his rook in the corner threes
guys and he'll try and bring it across
to the right side of the board
long term he's going to go for the
attack but okay he needs to continue
playing quickly magnus now having a bit
of think
yeah and uh wesley there talking to
himself just kind of like
come on what am i doing let me
refocus and readjust to the situation
and
yeah we see a trade and now i'm dying to
know
whether this rook will lift itself up um
magnus attacking the night so we
expect the night to well move behind
okay he moves back to where it came from
i wasn't expecting that choice yeah the
knight maybe had a safe a better square
in the center now magnus stepping
forward with his knight so white has
given up his dark square bishop traded
it off
but now white has complete domination on
those dashboards with his pawns
wesley challenging the center he's just
trying to pose problems for magnus but
that night getting kicked around again
magnus threatening that black knight now
yeah i know i mean just look at that
bishop it is a monster i mean
this is just instructive look at that
pawn that central pawn on e5 and that
bishop
those are a perfect attacking duo and
that is why wesley
desperately tries to close up the
position and now
the onus is on magnus time advantage
isn't that great though yeah magnus he's
got a fantastic position on the board
i would say actually strategically white
is just winning this is uh complete
dominance right now but the clock
situation that could come back to save
wesley if he's able to continue
playing quickly and eat away at magnus's
time advantage
okay magnus just stepping forward all
the white pawns now on dark squares
great set up for now for white black and
barely move actually black needs to
maybe bring
the black knight back away to a safer
square retreat that
magnus i was i was gonna suggest just
take that knight off the board
and he does but it cost him time
two and a half just under two and a half
minutes against under two minutes
look at how bad black's bishop is it's
just doing the job of a big pawn
it's just protecting things it's never
going to be on a great diagonal
black's knight as well misplaced magnus
needs to start attacking with his rook
there we go on an open line
attacking some of black's weak pawns a
still fantastic position for magnus
i feel like the clock's going to decide
this one though it's gonna come down to
a mad scramble at the end there's still
so many pieces so much tension on the
board and there's your rook lift david
rick moving three squares just so that
he can double along and attack
the pawn and magnus quickly applying the
pressure
and now it is that pawn the pawn on f5
that is within its sights
yeah white tonight eyeing up targets
maybe it will even drop back and re-root
itself there we go the white knight
dropping back
it's aiming towards better squares it's
going to try and jump forward again
and then attack black's bishop wesley
shaking his head he slowed down the pace
he's still 40 seconds down on the clock
and he retreats his bishop i mean that
does feel like a concession and
well magnus pushing his pawn there
okay so is there some chances now that
there is a bit of a
sneaky move there by wesley yeah i'm
surprised that
magnus allowed this trade of bishops if
they if it does happen it does happen
i'm surprised magnus allowed that
because black was cramped any trades
will actually free up black's position
but magnus is so dominant maybe
that he is okay with that trade black's
knight attacking some pawns white's
queen defending them
white tonight expect that piece to do
the heavy lifting now yeah and now the
fireworks appear on the board as
wesley goes completely crazy on the
right side
look at white's porn formation though
completely blocking off black any active
plans that black had
black's king stepping forward magnus can
just capture a pawn i think
yeah that looks like a free pawn why can
just play pawn takes pawn on the right
side of the board
wesley big trouble now on the board and
on the clock still
yeah well uh 53 seconds and ticking down
whilst magnus has just under one and a
half minutes
i agree with you magnu wesley is in big
trouble but still
yeah still everything to play for still
everything to play for at least he's got
one piece active the black rook
now finding a really nice square eyeing
up the white king indirectly
magnus bringing his queen across that is
that's that's a bit
strange i mean allowing black knight to
jump forward and capture report
exactly okay magnus has he calculated
this one correctly black does take that
pawn white queen also
capturing suddenly whose king is weaker
i don't know
i'm not sure if the players know either
in armageddon blitz chess
king safety is is everything it's
paramount white's queen however
very active magnus going for the kill
now he's pushing his pawn forward
yeah well this is a nice move by wesley
you know offering to trade queens
but 28 seconds to complete the rest of
his
wesley's not gonna make it yeah i think
he's gonna lose on the clock wesley if
he doesn't lose on the board
he still needs to save it on the board
especially after that last move white's
for it getting active
wesley's smiling he knows it's gonna be
all over soon
20 seconds and magnus wins wow look at
that
magnus carlsen in armageddon
finally beats wesley so and look at that
reaction that is
huge